you know it's really funny I was
thinking about this today I think I met
you
it's insane but it might be 30 years ago
it was over 30 when did you what season
did you start on the set you were the
new guy in season 1 I was the first new
guy not in season 1 but I think I was I
don't even remember I think I was I came
in about three years in or something so
was about exactly 30 years ago then yeah
and you could not have been nicer to me
and it's amazing I'll tell you this my
son is 14 years old and he's a comedy
fan and one of the ways that we bonded
meaning the first time he really looked
at me with respect was when he saw my
name pop up on a Simpsons episode and
then I thought I'm just kind of look
over and go like well you're not a
complete idiot but it was so funny cuz
he didn't even know you were coming on
the show and two days ago he just
brought up your name and he said do you
know how many voices a friend of his
challenged him to name all the people
you voice on The Simpsons and he started
rattling them off he couldn't get them
all but I guess that's a challenge for
real Simpsons fanatics is how many
voices has Hank Don what do you think
it's been it first of all your I guess
it's no surprise that you're raising a
real comedy nerd there but that's
another conversation that was mandatory
he's really good at sports but I broke
his wrist so they yeah you want to
discourage that yeah yeah no son of mine
is gonna be good at sports I don't know
why you were northern England yeah and
that improv but yeah it depends it now
you can't like if you go if you look at
some website I have like a two hundred
and some-odd right but like most of that
is just one line that I did is my own
voice you know in whatever episode but
for all intents and purposes there's
like 30 to 35 running characters that
I'll really do every week but every
sound I can make has been harvested for
this show every human noise that I can
make
every voice I do has been used in the
last 32 years I was always impressed
with how much you guys you really put
your all into these people and I think
sometimes doing some of these characters
like Moe that's tough that's like shreds
your cords yeah Moe yes raspy so if you
talk like this for too long
eventually you're gonna you're gonna
shred yourself and I'm not screaming
then you really gotta I gotta save the
screaming for the end and you know
you're right we do put our all into it
which I learned watching when we met I
was 24 or something right
I learned watching especially dan
Castellaneta and Harry Shearer and how
they committed so fully which I was so
wide out like wow this guy's really go
for it they're not embarrassed at all
even though there's a mic and yeah
there's certain voices I saved like
Duffman will blow me out in a second I
have to say but the end I actually dread
it like like oh no I'm an Adu today
right it actually does hurt I'm not
complaining this is very good yeah you
you were not allowed to complain you
know what here's here's an anecdote for
you I once though my voice blows out
rather easily
there's have to watch it and I was
having a rough time in my life and I got
in a screaming match with someone like
really no kidding around like who's a
really bad right and even worse than
that like it's in my car afterwards and
I was like school it was so upset and I
totally blew out my voice like I really
blew it out and it didn't come back for
almost two weeks and I got really scared
like I couldn't get like beyond here
which is in my line of work a disaster
as you might ask exactly and I actually
I scared myself so bad that I got my
vocal cords insured really I did
you're always like you know you've heard
like Baryshnikov insured his legs yes
pianists insure their fingers it
actually kind of makes sense that you
would insure your vocal cords I did I
mean if you think about what I'm lucky
enough the river
I'm lucky enough to bring in from doing
the Simpsons I mean that was a long time
ago a lot of money would have gone by by
if I couldn't make voices anymore is
there if after all these characters and
all these that you've inhabited is there
one that's your personal favorite like
it's just always fun to do the one I
love the most is Mull cuz he sounds like
he's from Queens and I'm from Queens and
I used to bartend and he currently
bought tens the one I enjoy the most
hone in my friend is Professor Frank and
to me it's the vocal equivalent of a
peanut I cannot stop once I start
growing I simply cannot stop it annoys
the doodles out of my wife but I I by
much enjoy it one of the things I can I
always tell is you guys do great improv
so many great improv with all the
characters but with Frank I can tell
that you get to throw in the kitchen
sink you know little little things that
you can throw in there yourself know it
amuse you exactly and with each take
I'll add one and I never want to stop
but the first line will be you know
fairly straight for him like hello Conan
how are you take two will be hello Conan
how are you hi and I won't want to stop
too by the enemy I the monologue that
follows is Lola
hello Conan how are you he said when he
was sitting in tight jeans thing that he
shouldn't be and they'll eventually have
to say enough we got it I'm sure cuz I'd
like to keep going
I know I know those are probably days
where they're like no no seriously you
know recent Jean or whoever were like
we're good and you're like no no I want
to do this 45 more minutes
yeah something you can't be depressed
making that I think that's what it is
it's like a natural mood elevator if
you're down and you start talking this
way it's very difficult to remain
depressed come and try it at home some
day you should try just doing a
something very serious with that voice
like if you ever asked to give a eulogy
you should get up there
and you it is Frank uncle Phillip was a
delightful man yeah that would that was
sort of the that was how we kind of
created Brock Meyer was right there's a
baseball announcer who talks like this
does if you put this voice in every
circumstance you know having sex or
wasted on drugs or in a very serious
relationship discussing with his
girlfriend is it does it still sound
like this understood because they still
give the count afterwards you know it's
funny because I think younger people may
not know this but I saw it right away
with Brock Meyer is that you are
channeling and how I mean it's changed
but that's how you had to sound in the
seventies yeah and you know into the
eighties if you wanted to be in you know
a color announcer or just a a
play-by-play announcer that's how you
had to sound and it wasn't only sports
announcers it was a lot of any
television pitchman right the Ginsu you
know in Japan the hand is a lethal
weapon but this theory does not work on
a tomato it's the Ginsu in Japan the
hand can be used like a knife but this
method doesn't work with a tomato that's
why we use the Ginsu or you know Popeil
always PO peels pocket fisherman was
always this voice selling you that was
like the generic vanilla I don't know
television voice announcer voice and it
bled into sports and and then Harry
working with Harry Shearer on The
Simpsons who you know his Vin Scully is
so beyond dead-on that you can't tell
the difference between him and yeah well
he we would joke around he pointed out
that baseball announcers can say
anything they like as long as they give
account afterwards so that was a lot of
the genesis of the brock mayer thing too
is how inappropriate can can you speak
on the air describing your sex life or
your drug use and then you know as pedro
delivers us latter into the dirt whoa no
no